[Music]
when you roll up to that line you are
getting butterflies in your stomach
you're nervous you're sweating but once
you get the bug you get hooked and then
that's all over
[Music]
we're celebrating our 23rd year of the
top-two cop program here at Sonoma
Raceway top the cops is a program where
high school students can come out to the
racetrack on a Wednesday night race
their car against a uniformed policeman
in a stock police car
I'm Kevin McKinney the program director
for the top the cops program
I'm a retired law enforcement officer
from Santa Rosa Police Department we've
been doing this from April through
August for the past 23 seasons
there was illegal street-racing being
done in and around the city of sin
tourism and I thought we need to get
these people over here to the racetrack
so they stopped doing that out on the
street if you want to race fine come on
out here and race don't do it out on the
street
[Music]
these are our future these kids here I
pull up next to a cop at the start line
I always just think great if I beat them
it's a great feeling when you pass them
on the guy kept going 100 miles an hour
there is a very competitive spirit to it
but you know it's all about the kids
there's a lot of negativity in the world
today a lot of negativity towards law
enforcement what we try to do out here
is make something good something
positive out of this program something
that is worthwhile
nowhere in the country is this being
done on a regular basis the top the cops
program did help curb illegal street
racing it's been a great positive
program all these years
[Music]
you
[Music]